Hey game developers, are
you excited for Android L?
My name is Shanee, and this
is what's new for games.
Google I/O was just
a few months ago,
and we have announced
some cool things
like Android TV, which works
with a game controller.
We also played with Cardboard
for virtual reality,
which you can assemble on
your own from cardboard.
While it would be really cool
to talk about bringing games
to TV and virtual reality, I'm
going to focus on these topics
here.
If you're familiar with the
Google Play game services,
it is interesting to note there
are a few changes coming in.
First, we took the
Cloud Save feature
and have given it a
facelift with Saved Games.
Saved Games offers an
improved user experience,
allowing you to upload
up to 3 megabytes of game
data with an additional cover
image for the user to see,
acting as a bookmark
and reminding them
where they left your game.
But that's not all.
We are also adding
quests, which you
can use to trigger
events in your game.
Quests are a fun way
to make your game more
alive and dynamic without having
to download a game update.
For example, how about a
shiny sword for 50 zombie
heads this weekend?
Awesome.
Simply go to the Developer
Console and declare a new quest
and set up a reward
for your players.
Use them to engage your
players and keep them active.
For more information
about the new features,
check out Duncan's
video on what's
new in Google Play Games.
The following
features are coming up
with the Android L SDK.
You can already find them
in the new [INAUDIBLE]
and the Android L preview.
We are adding support
for 64-bit architecture.
64-bit hardware has twice
the number of registers
and should boost our
game's performance.
To compile for it, you
need to specify support
for a target platform.
We added explicit support
for arm, x86, and mips.
Simply add the target ABIs
inside your application
make file, and you
are good to go.
A really cool addition
for graphic programmers
is the new OpenGL ES 3.1 API
and the Android extension pack.
We are really getting to
desktop level graphics here.
This can be used to
enhance your game's
features and performance.
The biggest changes
is in the pipeline
with the addition of
three new shadow stages.
Let's take a more
determined look,
starting with Tessellation.
Tessellation shadows take
geometry and subdivide it,
adding additional
triangles allowing
you to increase the level of
detail dynamically on the GPU.
[INAUDIBLE] for this video.
Geometry Shadows, on the other
hand, take a single vertex
and can output multiple new
vertices, making a new mesh
or extending the existing one.
These are great for particles,
glass, and even shadows.
And finally, Compute Shadows.
This video by Nvidia
shows Compute Shadows
been used for creating complex
animations and effects entirely
on the GPU.
You can use Compute
Shadows for many things,
from complex physics,
high-quantity lights, and even
AI.
The last we've
changed the graphics
is the addition of ASTC
texture support on the GPU.
This means you can copy the
textures by data straight
to the graphics memory,
reducing the memory
footprint of your application
and the loading times.
Like all compressors,
ASTC ports as a texture
and provides a
lower-sized output
with some quality differences.
The variety in the
difference of the image
shows ASTC is quite
high quality, hopefully
in a good exchange between
reduced size and speed compared
to image quality loss.
You can set different block
footprint for compression.
The larger the block, the
smaller the image file.
But more likely, the image
differences will be visible.
Finally, we have improvements
to the OpenSL audio API.
We have lowered the
audio input latency,
offering reduced lag
between recording your audio
and outputting it
back to the user.
You can finally make that mobile
karaoke game you always wanted.
We also added support
for multi-channel mixing,
allowing you to send
your audio output
to more than two channels.
If you're expecting
your game to be played
with a surround system--
for example on Android TV,
maybe-- you should really
take a look at that.
Finally, we added support
for floating point buffers.
These provide high dynamic
range, consistent accuracy,
and more head room.
For more information on
floating point in audio,
take a look at Glenn's
video, "Will it Float?"
Check out the new NDK 64-bit
target from the Android
Developers website to play
with the new features.
And don't forget, use
Google Play Game Services
to drive engagement
in your games.
Thank you for watching.
Now go ahead and
make your games even
more fun and visually
stunning with the new features
in Android L.